in the last video we studied a super
simplified economy that only sold one
good or service but now let's think
about things a little bit more generally
or a little bit more of you know more
complex economies and let's say that in
year one
in year one
economists have determined that the the
level of prices of the goods and
services produced in that economy is a
hundred
so they've they've essentially just you
know they've multiplied and divided by
the right numbers so that they their
index that they generate just says that
that is 100 and they do this so that
they can measure the prices in other
years relative to year one so let's say
in year two
year two
year two
using their index they realize that
prices are now 110.
now this is not a simple thing to do
this would have been a very simple thing
to do if there was only one good or
service in the economy like in our last
example apples you could have just taken
the price of apples it went from 50
cents to 55 cents in the real world this
is not a simple thing to do you have a
gazillion goods and services some prices
go up some prices to go down the
quantities of the goods and services
change in fact there might there might
be goods and services that were offered
in year one that don't exist anymore in
year two and there are their goods and
services in year two that didn't exist
in year one but for the sake of this
video let's just assume that our
economists are able to say this if you
call the general level of prices a
hundred in year one it's now a hundred
and ten or another way to think about it
is things have gotten ten percent more
expensive now if we're assuming that we
have we know this relationship and once
again it's not an easy thing to figure
out
and it actually turns out there's no
perfect way to do this
how can we figure out a relationship
between real gdp and nominal gdp and
remember whenever we talk about real gdp
so we're going to talk about real gdp in
year two so real gdp
in year two whenever you talk about real
gdp you're talking about gdp in terms of
the prices in some base year so in this
example we'll think about real gdp in
year two in terms of year one dollars so
whatever was whatever that were the
goods and services that were produced in
year two we're going to think about what
if they were at the same prices as in
year one and that will give us the real
gdp in year two so one way to think
about it is really just a ratio so the
ratio so let me write nominal gdp
so this is gdp in year two
measured in year two dollars
divided by
divided by i guess we could call this a
proportion really divided by the real
gdp
in year two and this is measured in year
one dollars
measured in
year
one
dollars well that's going to be the same
thing as the ratio of the prices between
year two and year one this is going to
be the ratio of
we use this indicator right over here
110
to 100
110 to 100 and i want you to just sit
and think about this for a second it's
just saying look the same goods these
are measuring the same goods and
services the real gdp is measuring them
in year one prices the nominal gdp is
measuring them in year two prices so if
things got 10 percent more expensive
between year one and year two the
nominal gdp should be ten percent larger
than real gdp we should have the exact
same ratios and now we can manipulate
this thing using any type of algebra
that we want for example we could say we
could say well nominal gdp and i'll just
write nominal now but this is where i
kind of specified exactly what we're
talking about this is a nominal gdp of
year two so now we could say nominal
nominal gdp is equal to we can multiply
both sides times the real gdp
is equal to
110
over 100
over 100 times the real gdp
times the real gp real gdp and remember
this is nominal gdp in year two this is
real gdp in year two measured in year
one dollars
or we can measure we can divide
we could divide both sides of this
equation by this 110 over 100 and then
we get nominal
nominal
gdp in year two divided by
divided by 110 over 100
divided by 110 over 100 is equal to real
gdp
is equal to real
gdp
real gdp in year two this is nominal gdp
in year two i won't i'll write it
nominal gdp in year two and writing it
this way it kind of feels like you're
taking your nominal gdp in year two and
prices have increased there's been a
general increase in the level of prices
that's called price inflation we see
that right over here
and now we're deflating it to get real
gdp we're dividing it by the ratio of
the prices we're dividing it essentially
by how much the prices have grown or i
guess you could say the ratio between
the year two prices and the year one
prices so this quantity right over here
is 1.1
so another way you could think about
we're deflating the nominal gdp in year
two to get the real gdp in year two
we're getting it in remember this is in
year one prices
year one prices and because of that this
number right over here this number right
over here is referred to as a deflator
this is our gdp gdp
deflator you pick a base year you pick a
base here in this case it was year one
that base year could have been 1985 it
could have been 2006 who knows what it
could be it could be anything your gdp
deflator is going to be relative to that
base year it's going to say well if that
base year was 100 your deflator is going
to say how much things are now in that
this year and you can even go backwards
in time year 0 the deflator might have
been 85 because maybe things have gotten
cheaper or you could have actually had
prices go down you could have actually
had deflation so maybe in year two your
deflator would be at 98. but the reason
why it's called a deflator is because
generally you have inflation as time
goes on and generally you're going to be
deflating your nominal gdp you're going
to be dividing it by a value greater
than one it's going to be something over
100 divided by a hundred which is your
base year to get your real gdp